After two weeks of wear a pair of jeans will
have grown a 1,000-strong colony of bacteria
on the front, 1,500–2,500 on the back and
10,000 on the crotch.
The whole country of Liechtenstein can be
rented for $70,000 a night, for a minimum
of two nights.
It sleeps 900.
More Falklands veterans have committed suicide
since the war than were killed during it.
The Queen of England is related to Vlad the
Impaler.
Aerosmith have made more money from Guitar
Hero than from any of their albums.
Arabic words are written right to left, but
Arabic numbers left to right.
Arabic speakers reading anything with a lot
of numbers in have to read in both directions
at once.
A single bolt of lightning contains enough
energy to cook 100,000 pieces of toast.
A greetings card that can play 'Happy Birthday'
has more computing power than existed in the
whole world in 1950.
In 2010, Ghana banned the sale of second-hand
underpants.
The King James Bible has inspired the lyrics
of more pop songs than any other book.
Harry Houdini could pick up pins with his
eyelashes and thread a needle with his toes.
70% of all animals in the jungle rely on figs
for their survival.
In 2010, the Catholic Church had an income
of $97 billion.
Mussolini tortured his enemies by forcing
them to swallow massive doses of castor oil.
In the US between 1983 and 2000, there were
568 plane crashes. 51,207 of the 53,487 people
aboard got out alive: a survival rate of 96%.
If you drilled a tunnel straight through the
Earth and jumped in, it would take you exactly
42 minutes and 12 seconds to get to the other
side.